i wanted to create a short video on the
six things that men
should not be eating all these things
increase
estrogen and shut down your testosterone
and that's not good because it can
affect your
your muscle density your overall
endurance your
energy your vitality it can trigger
erectile dysfunction
a decreased libido it can put on weight
it can create man boobs and the list
goes on and on and on
all right number one flax now check this
out
flax this is a phytoestrogen okay
it has way more estrogen
than even soy and soy is high in
estrogen
so flax is a no-no for
men the only situation i would recommend
flax
for females is if they actually have low
estrogen so flax is something you want
to avoid
flax seed anything connected to flax
flax oil and then avoid soy and that
includes
soy protein isolates
that can also increase estrogen all
right next one glyphosate
and atrazine these are two herbicides
the first one is involved in gmo the
second one is just a
chemical that they spray on our foods
both of these increase estrogen
and so the solution for that is to do
organic foods
next one is red dyes red dye has the
capacity to increase
estrogen pretty significantly now if
you're doing my version of the ketogenic
diet which is the healthy version
chances are you're not going to consume
any red dyes so i just recommend
you do my version of the ketogenic diet
i put a link down below but red dyes
not good tap water especially if you
live in the southern
part of the united states tap water
has significant amounts of
estrogen as well as other bad things as
well
so you want to get a filter to get that
filtered out
i mean you just don't want to drink any
tap water this not just estrogen there's
a lot of other chemicals
and the thing about water is that most
people drink a good amount of water in a
given day
so if you're you're drinking a lot of
tap water getting all that estrogen
that could be the reason why you may
have low testosterone right there
okay milk and milk products i'm not
saying
to avoid it completely make sure that if
you consume it it's
from grass-fed cows make sure it's
non-gmo
preferably organic and do smaller
amounts
now i'm not recommending milk but i'm
talking about cheese
so just make sure you don't overdo it
with the cheese
especially if you want to maintain your
healthy
testosterone levels hey before you go
real quick
i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i
want you to take it
and here's why here's you
here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can
tolerate and resist
your environment much better by
strengthening
your own immune system i put a link down
in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today